the case against five of the men accused
of plotting to kidnap michigan governor
gretchen whitmer
is heading to the grand jury prosecutors
say their evidence includes this video
of what they called a field training
exercise
they also have a map allegedly drawn by
one of the men showing the area around
whitmer's home
lawyers for the suspects argue listen
they never intended to kidnap the
governor
she's been challenged by right-wing
protesters who object to public
restrictions to fight the coronavirus
president trump blasted the democratic
governor's handling of a pandemic
a campaign stop in michigan on saturday
responding to the crowd chanting lock
her up
mr trump at that point seemed to enjoy
those words and then said lock them all
up tony asked governor whitmer to
respond to that tony what'd she say
about that
hey well this is a serious business
around here gail the governor told us
that every comment like the one we just
heard
means that the threats to her life
increase and whitmer also said that she
has asked the white house directly
to bring down the heat what kind of
response do you get
it falls on deaf ears every time they
haven't done a darn thing and in fact
10 days after a plot to kidnap
to put me on trial and then to murder me
ten days later they're back in michigan
using the same rhetoric i've been asking
them to turn the heat down
it is dangerous
now another michigander ronna mcdaniel
the gop's national chairwoman she says
actually the governor
is the one who's being inappropriate we
joined her she went door to door talking
to voters we're gonna have more on that
later in the show
it's a hard-fought race here gail uh we
also uh
talk about we're also gonna talk about
how the president is trying to appeal to
suburban women here in michigan
and also why voters in detroit very key
area say this election is different
very different than 2016. back to you
guys tony looking forward to that time
to check your local weather at 7 19.
we are going to see warmer temperatures
as this work week begins
we'll also see more clouds